on Monday this is cool on Monday the
Easter Bunny will make his highly
anticipated annual visit to the White
House yeah happens once a year yeah and
get this so will Milania very very rare
that she comes by yeah you were like
Easter Bunny how somebody in Melania
she's here at the White House what else
is going on Bill O'Reilly in the news
after being accused of sexually
harassing five women Bill O'Reilly is
going on a vacation to Europe
O'Reilly said he's looking forward to
hearing the phrase you're creeping me
out in seven different languages I've
never heard that you're standing too
close yes what else is going on United
Airlines announced it will no longer use
police to remove people from flights
nice they'll also stop using pepper
spray on passengers who asked for a
second bag of peanuts that's right
that's the comment states do that yeah
I've seen that happen taze you for an
extra pillow yeah
tase his first class after receiving
death threats the head of the EPA Scott
Pruett people are mad at him mm-hmm you
know so after receiving death threats
the head of the EPA Scott Pruett
requested a fleet of round-the-clock
bodyguards
yeah fruitwood said if I'm gonna die I
want it to be from good old-fashioned
unregulated coal emissions the way God
meant us to die a study just came out I
thought this is weird a study came out
you see this Andy I probably I was in
the monologue meeting
this is the part where we pretend we
didn't prepare oh and I was just reading
the newspaper and you're my buddy who
just sits over there behind a weird
pedestal okay what stories that buddy a
study found that babies as young as six
months old can be racist yeah or a Steve
Bannon calls them prodigies ma'am I
cannot read your sign she says woman
keeps holding a sign I need glasses or
binoculars to see everyone's what is
that your
[Music]
no that's our show
home viewers don't get the wrong idea
that's not going to work every time
right this isn't Denny right
you